well that was cool hello I'm Nicole Byer
and I'm the host of nail that on Netflix
this is my my head judge he is a French
Bulldog
motor of everyone and today we have Jen
from today you are making a cup of cocoa
mousse the classic French we need cake
up so impress that you like to do thank
you sounds hard Jen
you should go start now yeah all right
kokin bouche combined five cups of milk
put it in a stove what are you waiting
for
why can't you just assemble no because
you need to boil so you we don't need to
boil you are some on everything and then
you cook it no the next part of the
recipe involves heads one cup of milk
cornstarch and mix until it's Lurie
first mix until slurry floors chill now
gently strain the mixture its frothing
what she was doing on the phone 60 maybe
maybe higher class butter should melt
really taken care of itself
she's fine shows the water can't be
better and she stir it so she's supposed
to bring that to a boil and add the
flour okay let's see what's up all right
I trust you because I literally don't
know what she's making oh this is
boiling okay cool alright so we're gonna
take us off the heat
and sift the flour yeah I think she's
ready she's purred like a kitten
wow this is really satisfying and this
dough is really liable to be crunchy for
us I don't want it to be grinded [ __ ]
one ate it no no I have eaten so many
shells on our show that it's sad it's
cuz you're on it you're never going to
be stronger yeah but my nails are fake
I have piping bags no no no no okay cool
hot she's pretty
so I'm going to take these and pop them
in the oven and I will be seeing them
later so these are my beautiful pastries
they're fresh out of the oven and I am
NOT gonna lie you they are they're a
little flat he's too flat you come up to
the pastry cream in it
mm it's a little vertical and we're just
gonna try and fill it so you just have
to create a little bit of it with
speaker clicks oh happy Pride Month
everybody now we can fill it there we go
once it's filled you just sort of poke
so it looks like it never had an open
combine sugar and water once this is
ready I'll be able to start constructing
my croquembouche this is my cake stand
and my dumbs cap what is
this what did I mean so yeah I think we
should just do it yeah put the cream in
all right so this is the time number two
of the caramel making progress love it
that's too big they look like pitas they
do this does look like a bunch of mini
pancakes all right so this is my
croquembouche she's beautiful she's
finished and I can't wait to throw it to
jockey Nicole I think Johnny's done
let's taste what she's made so everybody
this is my final conclusion nailed it I
like it
yes thank you look like flat little
cookies I know they're filled with
something tasty I don't mind that it
doesn't look like it supposed to rock
what do you think look I might be not
very impressed with that that I'm
impressed with you because attempting
something like that it's a big project
should we taste them now let's do it
I think it's done somehow these are
truly tasty hey you guys have been super
generous with me I really appreciate you
it was disgusting I always bow down been
like to Jen for the fabulous gorgeous
tall job you did on those crumpets the
golden wheat cake yes I'm also really
excited because now I and everybody else
we can check out nailed it on Netflix
June 29th season to tony little's season
the new season is filled with more nasty
cookies nasty cakes wild looking things
where you look at it either
how on earth to the grown adult makes
that but truly they're beautiful in
their own
way rock of laughter yes love to laugh
so much
alright should be yeah Nicole I'm taking
a cake - oh oh yes